you know what's the best compliment that  I ever got is when in the month of  January people would say hat I don't  recognize you anymore something about  your walk something about your eyes  something about your look your energy  it's because in the month of December  and last week of November right after  Black Friday Cyber Monday when everybody  got a little bit more casual I had  business planning I had strategy  sessions I got Focus if you're watching  this you want to hear that compliment  well doing a Black Friday in the Cyber  Monday sale we have three different  bundles with over ten thousand dollars  of savings whether it's public speaking  course whether it's sales whether it's  strategy many different things if you  haven't yet taken advantage of these  click on the link above or below go find  out what these bundles are they're not  going to last a long time it's only  Black Friday or Cyber Monday we'll see  there